[Music]
hello everybody this is the first class
of play like a pro meaning we're going
to talk about chest legends and legends
we've didn't discuss or we want to
discuss in the future
so this first game I would like you to
guess the player who was playing white
so d4e 693 a five-night of six and
actually I'm going to talk about two
people not just one although I'll be
focusing on one person but enough talk
we for Tex 95 well kind of unusual stuff
happening on the chessboard it's not
like 21st century game clearly so
obviously I'm curious about the move
that's winning for a white but I'm even
more curious to know who's playing white
I'll give a hint for the player playing
white he is the namesake of the world
champion Oscar so his name is Edward
Lasker yeah you have a move yeah yeah
Queen take seven
yeah
if King moves back to AJ then indeed
Knight g6 is a beautiful check made by
advert Lasker who's actually far related
to the world champion Oscar but in the
game
Sir George Thomas who was a British
champion played King aged six question
is how to continue yes King g5 yep
King f4
g3 King f3 Bishop before I take
and if I go to GTA kingi one mm-hmm so
Bishop e2 check and this actually
happened in the game
kingi 1 but if we really want to be
stylish vamp castle and the black king
is doomed on g1 so today in play like a
pro I'm going to talk about two amazing
players Edward Lasker who made this game
with white against Thomas George and
also the world champion who was real
champion actually for 27 years and his
name is Emmanuel Oscar thank you so the
second game I'm going to show you is
Edward Lasker's game against Tracy
Richard matey Richard is very famous for
being the first hyper-modern player of
his time
the variation with Knight f3 g3 and
Bishop Bishop g2 castles is named after
eighty Richard
so e4 obviously this was all the hype in
the 20th century he 593 knight c6 Bishop
b5 can anybody help me what opening is
this yes there Villa PES yeah the
Spanish Bishop a4 I'd have 6 Castle
Bishop e7 rook e1 all very standard
stuff Knight a5 c5 this is in fact the
chick Orion variation d4 Queen c7 90 to
97 d5 f5 now
it's very interesting to look at games
from the 20th century because some
people assume that they don't know how
to play chess and that's not true they
just lived in a different time
openings weren't developed as well as
it's developed now but they still know
how to play this game and I'd advise you
to fill in the shoes of Edward Lasker
who at the time they say well had a
rating of 25 80 which would be in like
the 1990s would be like top hundred so
he's a very strong player of his time so
it's white to move and try to gain the
initiative so in chess whenever we don't
understand our opponent's moves we have
to question them at the board so that's
what we should do here
that's exf five so rate adjusts
sacrifices upon claiming that this d5 is
just too weak but Edward Lasker says
well prove it to me
Knight b6 Knight e4 and oftentimes in
these were Lopez positions it's more
important to have very active piece play
with d3 than to be up upon or having a
healthy Center Bishop a5 Knight g5 where
is this Knight headed when he goes
Knight g5 can anybody help me with that
yeah yeah the knight is heading to e6
and it it could be taken by the bishop
but most likely this Bishop is going to
get captured between d7 G for forcing
blacks hand and yeah indeed black could
take on g4 but takes takes King f1 and
this is not sufficient for black so he
takes on seater takes g6 Queenie for
defending the d5 pawn and also getting
ready for this night ecigs jump Bishop
g5 not g5
Queen b7 and seemingly this d5 pawn is
doomed but how can
Edward Lasker conjure up a nice counter
play in this position much White's
biggest issue in this position can
anybody help me with that the d5 the d5
is annoying
yeah Brooke do you want but rook t1
would just solve the problem it's a very
it's a legit move but in chess you can
defend your pieces or counter-attack as
mentioned before an advert lost Kirk
came up with a counter attacking move
here yeah
96 that's an idea but he played f4 so he
decided to attack the e5 pawn
therefore kind of balancing out the
weakness on d5 Finn takes d5 and now my
plate F takes e5 first he's happy to
take the pawn later so let's say D takes
e5 Queen takes e5 and when this Bishop
will manage to get out of its chain not
they're most likely to h6 then white
will have a decent position but rate
each owes otherwise played mukade Queen
takes d5 95 e 6 will get 6 rook d1 now
the idea is is to put pressure on the d6
pawn Knight c7 rook takes D 6 H 6 and
here Oscar found a small little tactical
trick which will eventually net him the
full game and the point why to move and
when I think 97 is also pretty good but
Lasker's moves as bit more safe where's
Aaron yeah
not f7 yeah but there's a stronger move
than nine f7
it's very close to the idea of night h7
but it's not as edgy yeah nighty for ya
94 and if I take on e6 yeah Knight f6
check and last care won the game because
the King moves I just take with check-in
anyways if you don't move into the check
you move away the rook is defended
so after rook takes f6 rook takes f6
Oscar Edward Oscar won the game quite
comfortably so the so I showed this few
games from Edward Oscar and he was very
strong but not as close as strong as
Emmanuel Oscar the world champion who
ruled our world for 27 years in the
world of chess and to understand his
conceptual understanding of this game I
chose this game where he played whenever
can anybody tell me why does whenever
Symons name is so familiar to us
he invented the French variation like
here ye6 d4 d5 Knight c3 Misha before
this is called the vin Navarre variation
which is christened after him but here
in lost care play d5 Knight c6 Bishop b5
Knight f6 castles 94 and we entered the
lines of the Berlin d4 Bishop e7 Bishop
e7 is the old line now everybody plays
Knight d6 and get extremely exciting
positions not instead so lost care
played Bishop e7 you know though he what
wasn't playing than i D
excellent anyways we need to 96 takes
takes D takes 97 now I know that this
position looks fairly weird from the
first look but black is hoping to get an
advantage from these bishops having this
bishop pair and also hopes to break free
with an idea of d5 later on so let's see
that luster is more of a positional
player and a gritty one at that 94
hoping to jump on f5 obviously Oscar
castles Knight c3 Bishop c5 Knight f5
and here lost care finds very very
typical but very strong move in the
position yeah these six d6 a little bit
is the idea is correct but it's a little
bit timid d5 yeah and the trick is that
there's no II takes d6
cuz boom will take the knight and then
will be a happy camper
obviously maneuver doesn't blunder it
plays Queen g4 now what lost kurds it
yeah
96 I would take the g7 and you wouldn't
be happy afterwards yeah
g6 that would be playing with fire
because your position would be filled
with holes you don't want that that's
not good that's not what lost grip late
last year took on f5 mean f5 rook e8
very principled chess he is immediately
putting pressure on the e5 pawn Bishop
f4 it should be 4 and this Bishop is
actually working very hard right now
putting pressure on the e5 pawn while
also pinning down this knight on c3 the
only place the knight can go right now
is a 4 or a d1 but none of them is too
appealing rookie one night c5 and you
can see how all of lost Kurt's pieces
come to alive in fact Oscar is planning
to play rugby eight hitting on b2 the
huge advantage and it's only moved 15
but Lasker is clearly in the dominating
position already rugby one Bishop c3b
takes c3 in c8 now what is really
important in lost Chris games that he's
trying to find the best moves and
actually that's the reason he's kind of
the big favourites of Viktor Korchnoi
and other super grandmasters because
first he looks for the best move second
he's trying to figure out what will be
the long-term advantage in that position
so it's kind of trying to combine ideas
of positional chess and tactical chess
Queen h5 Queen a6 now the queen is
already eyeing the a2 pond and those
weak bonds on C 3 and C 2 Ruki 3 Queen
takes a two
rook c1 Queen C for my screen C for such
a great move in this position yeah yes
so lost Kerr had a nice lunch on a 2 now
the Queen even though it's quite happy
there it would definitely would like to
help the King on g8 and some opportune
moments now that task could be done with
the idea of nighty 6 but one night is
not enough to defend the Kings side so
route KF 396 comes obviously as he's
trying to protect this g7 pawn forever
Bishop d2 rookie 7 Luke age 3 and here
comes the clincher move by Lasker what
the Lasker play here
now therefore I take on 87 so we never
sneakily attack the h7 pond neither fate
well then you jump around the lock with
your knife you try to conserve that
Queeny for as you said we're bringing
the Queen closer so we have a safe king
side and no wonder
Oscar is planning to exchange of the
Queens as the endgame will be dead
winning for him f3 queen g6 thank you
for losing a tempo Queen h4 rook d7 f4
84 and after my plate f4 this juicy
little Eve Foursquare is just perfect
for the Queen so he goes back there g4 9
f8 now he goes back as he falls by to
make these concessions so in general the
knight f8 idea is not bad but he wanted
to provoke some weaknesses and whites
King side and therefore he plane I have
faith later Queen f2 a5 so there's no
more mate and as bent Larsen would say
if you have an eye on f8 you'll never
get made it and it's 98% true you
shouldn't get made it with and I don't
have faith as it usually covers your age
7 pawn which is usually the weakest spot
in your position rookie three Queen c4
and all that Oscar is going to do after
defending on the Kings side is to
promote the ape on a 4 and there she
blows that rebel on the a line is just
marching a to h3 c5 so after he pushed
upon to a 2
he's trying to break in the center King
h2 d floor being a 3 c6
he's six also notice that manova is just
trying to conjure up some attack on the
other side
he might know he's losing but he still
does his best to come up with some
counter play take c6 Knight takes c6
but sadly there's no entry squares on f7
and f8 and then black is just winning
okay eight threatening the idea of
promoting and white resigned so this was
just to show that Lasker was aiming to
combine positional and tactical ideas
and that's how he became one of the
greatest chess players of all time just
one of them there are many of them
cousins should be considered one of the
one of the best ones but lost Kerr has a
place there as he was world number of
one for 27 years
alright now the second game I'm going to
show from a monohull Oscar is the
classical one that he played against
couple Blanca what is that so this is
the second game I'm going to show that
Lasker played against capablanca and
this is a very important game Bishop
takes c6 now this is not as popular the
exchange variation is not as popular as
before usually everyone plays Bishop a4
now what's kind of unique in LA scares
stylus that he's trying to play the best
moves in the position and not looking
for the beautiful moves in chess and
actually that's why he had some
misunderstandings with dr. tirage who as
Emmanuel Oscar used to say he looks for
the beauty for beauty in chess while I'm
looking for the strongest move possible
in on the board and here again we're
going to see last care doesn't really
bother to get an advance
he's just trying to outplay his opponent
which might not be such a big novelty in
today's age as cousin actually does the
same thing the four takes takes takes
Bishop d6 now d4 is not the move by far
castle is the best move here among
others but here already Lasker lost his
advantage but he's aiming to use this
majority that he has on the kingside
Bishop d6 93 97 Castle castle f4 and
that extra pawn on the King side is kind
of compensating for this healthy bishop
pair on d6 and c8 at rook e8 9 b3 f6 and
what actually I think male Oscar the
monorail Oscar one of the biggest
champions is that he was following no
rules he was following the rules of
trying to find the best move in any
particular position so it's white to
move and come up with a very good
strategic plan it's just quite unique at
the time this plan was new in 1914 there
are some rules in chess first rule being
if your opponent has a bishop pair try
to exchange one of them so he doesn't
have or she doesn't have one also if you
feel your opponent's pieces are active
try to restrict them now that's what
lost care did in this position yeah f5
indeed
and this Bishop on see it is kind of
terrible not green anymore it's actually
quite read because it's terrible it's
useless so he played b6 but lost crew
continued with his plan how did he
continue yeah yes with the idea of
exchanging of that nasty Bishop on d6
which could be nasty if it comes alive
on e5
so last care was quick to exchange it
off Bishop d7 and now strangely enough
this is a little bit inferior to the
idea of taking taking c5 and let's say
Bishop d7
and in the long term black tries to go
knight c6 Knight Knight e5 and black has
an okay position but kappa blanka was
trying to follow rules that didn't apply
to this position and play Bishop b7 as
in general do be like that doubled pawns
no II don't
but from stray far from strangely enough
in these Budapest positions these pawns
on c7 and c6 sometimes proved to be
useful coming back to this example just
for a second this c5 pawn actually takes
away this d4 square which is so pivotal
in these rule apes' exchange variations
so this should be 7 loss square took on
these six G takes d6
in 94 and now what's Kappa Blancas main
issue in this position right now
yeah
yeah bonds are weak and also this ecig
square is a huge hole that Lasker is
going to use to fool effect 94 roopd 896
rook d7 also apart from being very
passive black being very passive the
Knights feel very comfortable in this
half closed position I wouldn't even
call it half open because only white has
this diet this line opened for him on
the D line this Bishop is kind of a
sorry sight on b7 it doesn't do much
Knight c8 that's already a sign that
something has gone wrong
rook f2 aiming to double me five root D
- rookie 7 b4 b4 busker is kind of using
a method that is now known in them so
Indian variations you get rid of your
bishop and try to post your pawns on
squares that are opposed to the
opponent's pawn opposed to oppose it to
the b7 Bishop King f7 a3 Bishop a8 King
f2 ok it's G 4 on the other hand as
black has no chance of getting close to
their spawns on the Kings side white is
trying to expand over there h6 rook d3
a5h for white is patient the advancing
it takes a takes rook e7 can get three
room g8 let's stop here for a second
let's imagine we're black and we have
this position what would be potentially
the best idea to do here
how could black try to fight on
what move could provide cuppa Blanca
some chances for survival because this
is kind of those moments when cuppa
Blanca had his last chances of fighting
on yeah yeah that that's kind of
difficult because the d6 pawn is always
hanging all of our pieces with black are
very passive and one of the things you
can do when you have a passive position
is at least try to get rid of the active
pieces of your opponent so that's what
couple Blanca could do here but what
move would do that yeah
yeah the 5v5 that would just ruin the
structure yes yes rook takes e6 was the
last chance to fight on because even
though black is down material at least
he got a little bit more active most
likely he's going to lose the game but
at least he can put up a fight with g8
king f4 and also notice that luster is
not rushing with any pawn breaks he's
getting ready for the idea of breaking
through rook g3 he could play ideas like
g5 but there's no rush so he doesn't
play that g5 King f3 g takes h4 doesn't
certain anything because I just go blue
cage 3 and then pick up all those pawns
so that wouldn't work Knight b6 it takes
g6 ruk h3 now the monorail oscar has an
e6 night which is very strong plus the
rook on h3 on the only open file apart
from the a line so very soon the journey
for a cup of Blanca will end rook d7
king g3 King g8 group each one should be
75 and in order to activate this night
that wasn't doing anything even
sacrifices upon D takes e5 94 and now
this is just too much for kapa Blancas
position as the knight is headed towards
f6 and Knight c5 and even 96 95 95
already winning material Bishop c8 if
the rook moves we can just check and
collect material and that's just over
Bishop see a 97 locate 7 entering the
seventh rank
and now what might is trying to do is to
go around again and just collect
everything King d8 bouquet Bishop C
ignite c5 and Capablanca resigned
because night II 6 is coming and even
I'd be 7 is deadly
so the Oscar won the game so in this
game Oscar showed his skills that he can
win any type of positions just trying to
look for ideas that are very
uncomfortable for his opponent and I
feel that Capablanca wasn't accustomed
to this situation and that's why he lost
so badly in this game I'm gonna show two
more games one of them played against
Arash himself now I wouldn't say that
tarush is worse in this position but
look at the way
Emmanuel Oscar will try to put try to
put pressure on tirage his position
let's look at this position the first
time which pawn can become weak in this
position for black potentially
yeah c7 maybe yeah in the long run yes
yeah
a seven well a seven from practice I
could tell it's hard to get there yeah
f7 that's firmly defended by the king
that's the problem
yeah the e5 one the e5 one so noticing
that the e5 pawn could be potentially
leak Oscar starts with H for rook d6 how
did he continue
yeah h5 well that wouldn't help the idea
of undermining the e5 pawn you're trying
to find a move that will create a
weakness on e5 yeah
g5 yes a very strong move and this is
high high Grandmaster level I'd even say
super Grandmaster level black usually
wants to defend the e5 pawn with f6 so
it has control over the e5 square now on
the other hand if I've pawn will become
isolated so it will become a potential
target in the future each takes each
takes f6 rook g1 loss here doesn't take
on f6 he doesn't want to help this rook
to activate
so he says okay if you take on g5 good
for you
but I'm not gonna activate your rook and
let it into the F file and f4f takes
rook takes ninety seven c5 I'm not sure
that white was any better in this
position most likely King f6 would have
been much better but ninety-seven gave
this option of c5 to create a weakness
on e5 i mean ii v this is a pawn
sacrifice but for the pawn white will
get something what will might get for
the sacrifice pawn did i see your hand
there oh no I thought you raised your
hand
so what does c5 create apart from
putting some pressure on e5 well it
activates this d3 Bishop which was very
bad before c5 b takes Bishop e5 now
compared to the first position the
initial position we saw we have two
amazing pieces on g5 and b5 and why it
might even start thinking of getting
better because both of these pieces for
black are pretty bad King up six rogue
g1 9 f8 a for getting ready to advance
this pawn and might dream of becoming a
passed pawn in the future would be 6 in
d3 where is that King had it I wonder
well it's headed towards the sea pump so
lasker with the use of attacking the e5
pawn constantly constantly he created
another weakness on c5 and in chesty
release say if your opponent has at
least two weaknesses you can win the
game tonight h7 King c4 and now why this
clearly better Nagi five rubgy for
knight of seven king takes e5 the reason
might as clearly better is the fact that
he has an extra pawn on the Queen side
while also having by far the better
pieces compared to the black pieces nine
eight six Ruby g1 g v a5 and the problem
is for black that there's no way that he
can stop the White King from marching
forward rook d6 Bishop e2 I mean Rick d6
stops it but then I'll be able to attack
your pawns through this b7 square C for
not a fade Bishop g4 Bishop e6 bouquet
six king b5 rugby one here it comes
king c5 and now out of desperation
tarush took on e6 but that's basically a
non move after taking f6 working h5
really doesn't matter
I have route b7 and I'll just gobble up
this pawn on c7 and this pawn on d5 was
just marched forward and there's no way
of stopping that so you could see how he
won an equal position or maybe even
slightly worse position just by trying
to eliminate a bad pawn for himself and
also trying to create as many weaknesses
for his opponent as possible now I want
to close off with this game
another game that he played in the World
Championship match against Arash there
he actually comes up with some opening
ideas in the Vanara French the five
nights III Knight f6 now everybody plays
d5 but in the past even Alekhine played
Bishop g5 Bishop g5 Bishop before he
takes d5 a very rare move Queen takes d5
to modern standards Knight f3 c5 takes
takes Queen d2 and even though analyzes
from that time so in the 1920s 30s they
claim that this concept that Emmanuel
Oscar was choosing here is dubious it's
not quite true it's quite playable for
white they claim that Knight e4 is just
brilliant oh that's not quite true cuz I
play Bishop d2 takes B takes Bishop
takes c3 Xin no no and these French
structures the bishop is just terribly
placed here so you should take the C
pawn and even though it's doubled at
least it's a central pawn so that kind
of compensates here and c5 Bishop d3
takes Queen takes castles castles and
this these positions are equal but with
Mutual chances anyone's game
so that's say knight c6 Queen e3 and
White has decent chances of getting an
advantage but black has no reasons to
complain either okay but tirage didn't
go for that he went for the principled
c5 move takes takes Queen d2 I like I
always like these unorthodox ways of
defending pins this Queen d2 move
actually threatens this idea of Knight
takes d5 because even though let's say
let's say
let's say Bishop d7 takes even though
you take a check
King takes D to e takes d5 D takes e5
and apart from being a pawn up I will
have an eternal knight on d4 after
Knight d4 and night what is that
so Knight d4 and this will be an eternal
light there so torch was forced to take
on c3 takes 97 rook D 1 root g8 d takes
e5 Queen c5 in d2 and actually this
position reminds me of the game played
between Carson and Lamont where cousin
really badly outplayed Anand and similar
to this game
black will have trouble developing
because you can't really move the knight
because of ideas of Queen d8 mate so
tirage is dr. Tara she is forced to make
some moves and concessions Queen b6 c 3
a 6 and now I'd like to ask how should
we develop our pieces in this position
with white yeah
g3 indeed he played Queen c2 first but
after that he played g3 the problem is
for white that he cannot really go to e2
yet cuz the route would take on g2 and
you don't want to give a free pawn y for
Queen c2 at v g3 now the bishop is going
to this healthy square of g2 while it
will take some time for this bishop to
get out from this terrible square on c8
and move it to b7 he can do it but it
will cost him a lot of time night c5
Bishop g2 Queen c7 Queen e2 he wants to
have a firm grip on this ePHI square
therefore he plays Queen e2 we need to
be v castle bishop
seven and to be honest I feel that
Lasker totally outplayed tarush in this
position has he has a huge lead in
development and if you have a huge lead
in development and your opponent is not
castled yet it's high time to do some
action and that's what Amano lost care
does here he plays c4 why does he play
c4 can anybody help me what's his idea
of c4
what's his goal yeah okay repeat
yeah create a file please put a pressure
on this diagonal and then this line and
also the black king is in the center
that's what she wanted to say yeah that
that too that the pawns on b5 and a6 are
pretty weak so Lasker hits the iron
while it's still hot before Queen d2
again as you pointed out he puts
immediate pressure on the weak pawn rook
b8 dr. tirage is being tricky to screen
before wouldn't quite work because of
Bishop takes f3 and it would be a
Discovery but Lasker looks for a
different target and that move will put
even more pressure on terra's position
so why to move and white against the
initiative
whenever you're looking for a potential
move always think about where you can
find your opponent's weakest spots in
this position where can you find the
weakest pawns first we were attacking
this pawn on b4 but then the black rook
defended it so we need to find a
different plan this time yep yes green
eight six and even though this pawn is
not worth too much but it is a weakness
in blacks position and it's extremely
close to tarish as king no wonder that
tirage panics and just exchanges of his
most beautiful bishop which is actually
a no-no he really shouldn't have done
that takes Queen e5 rook e1 and even
though Oscar is not famous for
sacrificing when he sees the chance for
an attack he'll jump at it the first
opportunity he gets Queen takes B 2 and
now Lasker finds the key move that will
just make his attack decisive
yeah if Bishop c6 the king can move to
e7 and it's not not yet over
yeah that would be a little bit early
because of this good defender on c5
these sacrifices can be dangerous for
the one who sacrifices
whenever attacking you always need to
bring some more pieces into the attack
Shep age five
it's an idea but that's not what Lasker
played yeah
Bishop d5 well
I'll most likely play rugby six so what
class Kerr played was Queen f4 and they
were many tempting moves and I
understand that but lost care decided
okay I don't really need to get into
detail yet because if my Queen drops on
d6 this game will be over
so I think it took him like five or ten
seconds to find this move as if the
Queen does enter on d6 the threat of
Bishop c6 will be just brutal and indeed
he was correct rook c8 clean d6 now
Bishop c6 is quite hard to stop f6 but
if you stop me from playing Bishop c6
yeah then I call Plan B and play Bishop
h5 r g6 takes takes and rook takes six
and that changed the game and Taurus
resigned because after rook takes c6 the
Queen will just take and Queen takes c8
and that would mean game set match for
Emmanuel Oscars and thank you for coming
by thank you
[Music]